yeah  check or attack the bishop both will do  just attack something yeah that's the  key when in doubt attack something he  attacks the king  forces the king back  but uh okay but now is  maybe now you could consider taking off  the whiteboard with your rook  i think that is a draw just about  because you you because the black king  gets to the critical g7 square yeah so i  think we'll see this on the board  um and this is why you need to study  your end games you need to know exactly  what end games are drawn and which ones  aren't and we're going to see stalemate  one point alone is not enough and  ishkiri smiles  saves the draw  he finishes the day with a smile in each  gear but this basically sums up a really  bad day a bad first day in the  tournament for both levon aronian and  the nishkiri two of the very top  favorites but  they've lost some games today and uh  struggled but do you think a niche geary  managing to save a draw in the